okay back with our real thoughts I have
a really interesting one I want to do
because we just put this back up on
YouTube but are you know this I think is
a fast name movie to talk about I don't
like it if I think it's still intriguing
let's talk about Temple of Doom first of
all first up first up because there a
way to make sure this doesn't show up in
Brad's fees no I was gonna say okay so
the first time because if you see the
review we have a service a beast and
character commenting on it and I guess
after we did it like he was talking to
rod say keep made me say the most
horrible things yes favorite Indiana
Jones movie yeah Brad Brad was all like
the things I had to say things I had to
do I denied my favorite no I think
there's even like a blooper where I'm
trying I'm saying like nobody knows the
name of the villain and he says the line
and they turns and says the name of the
villain even now I get a rope that was
my favorite cuz that was all on you that
was not me because he comes up to me
like if ever view it's like what are you
two idiots like I'm like that was him he
wrote that and I knew what the guy's
name was all anybody remembers about
that guy unless you're a die-hard
fanatic as a takes the heart out he's
nothing like a bad actor uh I knew
exactly who there was no that's what
that is on you I want the world to know
that what I am i v you can't prove it
because they wanna be like you know yeah
I know the name you'd go Google and then
put it in it's like well but we wouldn't
know this so I don't know probably maybe
that's just you know like I didn't know
the guys name but but to be fair he's
definitely like you know how Donovan and
oh now we're gettin a the first guy
Belloc bella you know how they're kind
of similar in Last Crusade and raise a
Lost Ark and stuff it's like that dudes
like his own thing he's just completely
100% like no there's no similarities you
know it's funny I actually never thought
about it till you just brought that up
I'm like not that like a Donovan or not
I'm just like well they're both just
kind of working
for Nazis and selling their souls out to
get the mi older my oh my yeah actually
they both have like the die-hard creepy
Nazi guy to their side he's been a
criticized really enjoys his killing
that's always been a criticism of Last
Crusade now EastEnders a little
overplayed but yeah it's a little bit of
a legit point but no it is they did it
it might paint it a little better but I
take my advice it's really nice they
trust nobody dr. Jones
it's really tough which ones bear less
Crusader Raiders um oh I'm Raiders see I
asked your say is it close yeah see me
too I'm like just barely it's the Temple
of Doom
I like Temple of Doom more than you
however it is definitely a solid third
it is in no way like I can't even have
to be like oh let me think about it I'm
like no that is definitely the third
best a Crystal Skull for me is still
Rock one two then some space where you
get three that's Temple of Doom and then
Crystal Skull would be somewhere off
this see here's the interesting thing we
talked about this in the review how
people were just so diehard no to keep
the Crystal Skull yet for some reason
temple doom really gets kind of a pass
and in many respects there are so many
scenes in my opinion they're just a lie
but if there's also kind of this no no
no no no no no no cuz think about it
think about this is now sibling right
here's was getting to is that in my
opinion cuz you know there is just
almost nothing fun in Temple of Doom
it's just it's miserable it's unwise
rail right and I do agree on this that
Temple of Doom is a hard-r movie I don't
know where yeah I don't know where that
come it invented this for a movie this
is you know I will say this this is why
it is but hands down even though it's my
third favorite it's better than Crystal
Skull it is a hard our movie Braga's be
nothing what I was gonna say her Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull as far as I'm
fucking concerned that is a PG
movie posing as a pg-13 here's what I
was gonna say is that I'm much higher
groove oh no I think Temple of Doom is
kind of oh and it is it is kind of hard
to compare it but I I think it's a
little less I say I much rather watch
something that insane rather than
something that's dumb and kingdom of the
Crystal Skull is dumb temple Doom is
insane it is batshit insane insane but
it does have dumb moments which really
annoy the hell out of me
I see these going moments at Temple of
Doom are just so much more annoying to
me Brandon crystal skull Brandon
Willie and shortround and stuff and they
just I want to just boom their heads
together they are so sure wanna see
short round never bothered me
[Laughter]
award-winning line that's the thing with
Crystal Skull or a doll as it's dull
it's quiet oh you like that like a
million times the review though I can
see that one scene completely made it
worth it for me no more interesting than
Crystal Skull like 10 times more than
sure well for one thing practical
effects now that CGI shit okay
let's talk about where CT I really could
have helped this movie because the
practical effects are great but when
that water is going through the minds
and they're on the cliff and stuff like
that and they're superimposed in there
it's painful it is goddamn pain no they
weren't there the hell I mean it was
real water there wasn't a digital no I
agree but it's like they're so clearly
not they're running there so clearly not
on the ledge okay so that's a keying
problem you could feel but when you're
light easily no but that's what I'm
saying we're like
none of that CG CG would have saved
those effects if they blend up a bit
better metal has to be a mess you know
what okay
bullshit I have seen better keying
effects in other movies of that era and
afterwards not this one that's just
somebody got sloppy that's up because
lighten MCS hanging times no that's why
I'm saying that's not like you can't sit
here and be like that argument doesn't
make any sense it's just a shitty
special-effects somebody fucked up
that's what happened and that's up just
because oh well CGI didn't exist
therefore it looks bad
oh no like that you can even shoot no
you could shoot those scenes just as
they are and get close-ups of Indy you
know running away extra that era that
are still incredible and for the most
part hold up just because somebody
dropped the ball on that one effect is
like oh well that needed CGI obviously
but there GG I could have gone in and
fixed that bad effect and gone rid of
the law case sure you can come man you
can master that now and fix the King and
that's nice yeah that would have fixed
that really bad effect or I'll say just
shoot up at her you don't need to show
something running away there's no CGI
ants there's no CGI alien you think the
only CGI really liked in Crystal Skull
was when the UFO left I was like oh
that's kind of cool looking like no but
by far the ones up the whole like I kind
of actually liked that but by far the
worst CGI in Kingdom the Crystal Skull
with Shia LaBeouf uh you know it never
looked like he was there it never looked
like he was interested in what he would
say he was about interest charger brings
was interesting so I like the practice
okay
well here's an example the fucking CD of
the fire ants and everything I know
people whose job yet he could it give me
gonna get me a fire engine you got real
bugs in town but that's my point it's
just like you still they had real bugs
in Temple of Doom that's seen there's
real fucking bugs there and that seemed
like every time I'm just like oh I'll
give that actress credit for CAPTCHA up
not
justly annoying as she is well I want to
get to that well doctor the Neue she is
she went in with all those goddamn
animals insects bugs and stuff like that
and there was an interesting behind the
scene Peggy the person seems really cool
like the actress I give her the senior
cojones award for that no no cuz she was
saying like what she did to be in that
scene cuz she's terrified of bugs and
she says that you know she just did
meditation and she was training for that
dance so and you see her in the bimah
scene she's there just like this as
they're putting the bugs eye and she
said I just told him they are just
innocent little creatures and they're
curious and they just you know are
around you and stuff and then when they
said action she stopped with the
meditation I like how like SPEA like she
married Spielberg I would have been like
fuck you got no fighting he's like I am
so writing this scene for you hate bugs
but yeah or even will Allison duty and a
Last Crusade with the rats don't submit
nowadays what is CGI but your rats like
a friend don't dearly apparently well
apparently the story goes that that was
the case that she I know in reality I
think she's British so she doesn't have
that hot awesome it's like the best
parts of spoken for oh she's she's not
see what did you said that was that that
was the big issue she's like she wasn't
really so much scared of the rats as she
didn't want to step on them she felt bad
like so I all of these effects are real
and they're they're practical and I like
that about this movie that has an old
grungy kind of grimy and it's like it's
a fucking horrible
it's deaf
we're Raiders had elements of that 80s
what the flick this was all the way we
are in there what the phobia the intro I
love that was so 30s dude like that it
didn't if you know what they're spoofing
then
that straight-up was like I just look at
them like yeah it looks like 1936 to me
and no and even when he comes in the
freakin shish kebab the flame out
magical when he comes in you know that
the medication looking very humphrey
bogart looking very smooth I'm like okay
and he's sort of like they're trying to
make it as kinda like the anti here but
again you know I'm almost wondering is
it him or is it how obnoxious they made
her cuz Assoc comes in it's like God
just everything seems off and awkward
and weird and a half okay no okay
I gotta get to that event so it's half
what I like about the person is it's
half kind of thirties little bit of
screwball comedy that's also really dark
and I I like that right down to him
getting out the play and just like see
you later
hahaha good luck dr. Jones got his name
um no and I like the action I like the
Gong falling down him running a cry me
it's like the balloons it's like watch
it's not like the in joke club obi-wan I
like that I as ridiculous as it is and
that's where I lose my shit because
people and find I'm just like okay I
know I'm Mythbusters like technically
they've proven that maybe you can like
hop down on a raft and fly out an
airplane it but I'm like highly unlikely
so I like all that seed it's somewhere
then they go to the villages and all
their kids are missing you're you're my
dad you must do this and somewhere once
they get to the palace it starts to slow
down and I can't after the heart comes
out yeah I can't it's particularly at
yeah yes Don Carney mom it's like it's
all in unplug or in this movie by the
way than the fucking Mortal Kombat film
I'm never gonna let go
how's the patient nother pg-13 yeah goes
down into lava guess what screwed up
they think I'm writing in that Mortal
Kombat film how are you not seeing the
brilliance of that oh right I I don't
get it clearly mono so that was about
the writing that's a god okay we could
get up
Brad and I are actually in complete
agreement on this which is Brad's theory
is and I think he's a hundred percent
correct which is honestly this is about
two people that just really need to bang
and they never get to and that would
solve everything and I agree or than
1-hundred said here's the problem
is the biggest problem this is what
kills the movie for me is the person he
needs to bang his cake let's rather bang
dishes and this is where like brand I
are completed green we like everything
about this movie and this is where like
we're on the same path and we die for
her
cuz he's on the path of I like Kate
Capshaw in this movie and I'm on the
path of I hope she dies in a fire yeah
do it she is so so annoying like oh god
my ears there's something really weird
to about like any time I know I just
said that's what I wanted like and and I
will say this it's almost worth it for
Harrison Ford's reactions cuz you could
just see his eye twitching whenever she
talks you know but I just wanted
somebody's ready just shut up shut the
hell the scene and the only scene we got
that was close that I I'll of is yeah
it's gotta be dead bodies down here if
you don't hurry up there's an
interesting scene in this movie and I
never really thought about are paid much
attention to it but I was thinking back
to I forget I talked about in the review
but before he starts the quest is before
he goes to the palace says he's gonna
save the kids and stuff and he's looking
over this landscape this beautiful
landscape I pretty sure the sky or the
stars a blue screen or something like
that he's talking with short round and
it's interesting because I said you know
this is something Spielberg has I think
sometimes some directors are missing a
while make big movies but but there's a
missing problem this is a really like
you know what this scene is this is
supposed to be the okay you're gonna sit
down and think for a minute just sort of
talk
yeah could the show there's a little bit
of substance to this it isn't just
fighting and you know return the king
did that to like you know the calm
before the storm you know it's so quiet
yeah I mean that really is kind of what
it is and it's a beautifully shot the
pacing is right the acting is right what
they're talking about is really fucking
stupid they're just like yeah I'm gonna
get rich that's what it's about
we're torturing lorica in case you miss
that I'm totally gonna be like this at
the end I'm not setting up anything
total fortune and glory yeah you hear
that I'm like nothing well isn't that
fascinating that everything else was
right like where that scene was the
pacing the music it was just the wrong
that's a subject matter was nothing it
was nothing subject matter but they're
treating it like something really deep
and big story because we've we've
established in Raiders even though this
is a prequel establishing Raiders that
he's India I love him be like oh he's
the great American here I'm like he's an
answer yeah yeah no you okay he's he's
robbing graves
you know he's just plundering you know
what every damn well pleases when is a
chance save his girlfriend he has
multiple chances to save his girlfriend
he skips it you'll see what's in the BA
go ahead Jones blood blood the back to
God you know and he's just saying I was
her I would be like oh my favorite
happen to their anti dinner that I just
be like we are gone because when he's
got the bazooka Karen Allen turns arse
like Brock and like she smiles like yeah
this is it like this is happening
and then he's like yeah gon do it he's
like you want that we are passing
through history this dr. Jones is
history you know blow it back to God do
it any lowers the thinking I could just
imagine Marian's face just like so he's
not he's very much an antihero that's
I love about the characters he's not
perfect there's like this weird dark
edge to him so this was their way of
starting him off as like alright we're
gonna give him a soul that apparently
his breaking point is not saving his
girlfriend's ass but apparently like
little kids yeah and I think that's the
thing too that was also part of that was
like fortune and glory till I at the end
II like hands it over it yeah just how
orchard and gory kid like how friggin
obvious is Emmy its immediately set up
it's not you know he's gonna have that
change in everything and it's just not
like it looks like what I will sales
what I will say this this is a different
movie this is closer to a thirty
screwball comedy then I think Raiders
Raiders is not really that screwball I
think maybe this forget hearts being
pulled out in shit I didn't say they
mesh well together but there's what I
said one half of this is a screwball
comedy and the other is fucking what
Mortal Kombat should you know I feel
like you know that's interesting you
brought the comedy because both
particularly lassie maybe last true save
was like the okay this is what I was
trying to do with the comedy because the
comedy mix they're so well and it came
from the characters they came from Indy
and his father working off each other
and and just man Joey and this one is
not aside from her going there's no
comedy really with the characters and
one that is is an obnoxious character
and even like during the fight see it's
like the slapstick is so annoying like I
remember one scene
this guy the big burly guy has a
boulders like and he punches him he goes
and he lets the rock fall on his head
and drops his arms em like Christ the
weird thing about the movie is there a
number of scenes like and every time I
watch it the same thing happens I'm like
like the scene where the assassin tries
to get him against the wall yeah yeah
I'm like that's a good scene but I'm
like and yet I'm not overly invested in
this even though it's a great see that
he hangs the dude from the ceiling fan
layin and I'm like what is it it is
somehow that everything kind of works
alone as a single scene but when you
start pasting them together something
isn't clicking an F
every time somewhere in the middle of
the movie after the the poor sucker gets
his heart pulled out I kind of just
always like zone out and kind of until
the mine ride like the mine ride I wake
back up again went in a little bit again
just for the total dark almost creepy
element I get in a little bit when he's
drinking the bed Indy juice and it turns
him into bad indie and stuff I mean but
not even not what he's been doing the
transformation slapping Shore around but
no I thought when he's Lilly ladies
transforming it's a it's a good lighting
seen the better scene was when he was
getting all the weird shit and giving
that smile to Kate Capshaw like yeah I
love this and when it's more devilish
there and again and it's the one scene
that the main bad guy the one the one
time he's ever creepy he does have this
beautifully creepy smile and I've they
don't do this anymore in movies maybe
just Bruce Willis movie sometimes but I
love it in serve old action films when
the bad guy will kind of smile and say
something mean and then the good guy
kind of just smiles right back like yeah
yeah even though they'll know advantage
they're like you know they they got them
all chained up and stuff he's like oh
dr. Jones you see he just sits out there
and they're both like see I feel like
Bruce Willis movie so were the last ones
where I I saw those I don't really see
those scenes anymore
it's it's it's so hard to say just
because I don't hate this movie I think
I get bored by this movie particularly
in the middle I feel like it's
deliberately pasted to a point where I
get zones me out and it's really cated
the the pacing and Kate Capshaw are my
biggest problems if you had replaced her
with a different actress it was not as
annoying
I might actually like this film a lot
more um really the kid doesn't get you
know honestly I don't know I think you
can act you I away will wait
well Z with you in Goonies goodies yeah
and he's fine and he's a good actor
maybe he's totally fine if I just want
to strangle that little pain in the ass
that's the problem with the movie and I
think that's where is he
we're falling when it fell okay we're
falling on the kid we're Brad and I fall
on Kate Capshaw where he's like err
didn't bother me and I'm like God
bothered me but with the kid it's like
Edie didn't bother me but it bothers you
yeah it's a very thin line between cuz I
would argue that's the point that India
is saddled with these two on an
adventure that you should not I'm not
going to say you shouldn't have women
there but you should not have that woman
yeah definitely not have any kids then
any kid I wouldn't even take Newt form
aliens on this adventure um so so the
point is that you kind of like you
should kind of want to strangle them
like that's what Indies feeling but it's
a thin line between like oh yeah like
that's the point
and no I just really want to strangle
them personally so I and I get where
you're coming from and I've talked to
Brad about physic no I I get where
you're coming from like a lot of people
have a problem with Kate Capshaw's is I
think she's hilarious I'm like you know
I I don't but and there are there
moments very few but there's a moment or
two where Karen and Karen Allen gets a
little kind of like I think there's
somewhere in the plane scene when she's
stuck in there and she's some something
or no I know that was I married it's
when the torch is going like I'm like
but that's okay cuz that's a once thing
like the only one I took seriously the
whole way through it's fucking Elsa my
great you should get shot it on that
boat she turns around like so Elsa was
but and now we know why she's a Nazi
they're hardcore so but when frozen came
out by the way that was the hardest
thing to get used to because every time
I heard Elsa I think of you know
I can't hold you else Arne honey I can't
what I love we always love that he says
how do you never use any term of a
phantom the other hand not see I can't
hold you oh my little fear of love and
honey bunny no and I will say this again
which is like if you had to ask me which
film would I rather which film is worse
but which one would ever either watch
like I would strangely probably rather
watch Temple of Doom over Kingdom of
Crystal Skull Temple of Doom is of the
better film and I would rather one
because there are the scenes that are in
it are legit good scenes you know I will
I'd like the scene with the painting and
and the mind Jeff see and end up cutting
the bridge is great and that's my in
that that one seed where he goes to get
up the gun again mmm oh shut up okay
King of the Crystal Skull moment and I
see I like that let's see if it's only
the first direct sequel so I'm like that
you can have a callback here they're
like and I look I will say this the best
comic was in Last Crusade where he takes
the gun out fires it and it kills all
seven Nazis in a row and he's just like
holy shit yeah like that dad I thought
was the best callback to that seen him
Raiders but okay I will say this the
first of the bridge scene is amazing but
then in these read just kills you know
prepare to meet Kali shutting out the
Bulldog lower-tier Brad and I quote that
all the time but my favorite and I've
said this before to other people like as
much as I rip on Kate Capshaw's just
being terrible in this movie there was
one scene one scene where I think she is
acting her ass off and I believe every
single second that's great yeah well
okay there I thought that was good
that's mostly screaming though but you
wonder what one line reads she says hold
on then I'm just like I believe that
moment I don't know it's on the bridge
it sure ends like you know some like
hold on crazy ready we go far
and she like looks at a that there's
like this scene I swear got you like
looks and wooden he's about to do it
looks at her and like puts it together
and she just goes oh my I was just like
I believe that that's like the sound I
make when I'm on like one those 400 foot
tall rollercoasters going again one of
the great things about get seen it's a
perfect read she delivered that but I'm
like I believe like for some reason I
was like oh but Spielberg was cruel
enough to just be like yeah we're gonna
cut this bridge you're gonna go flying
up like she just had that look like when
you know and that whole scene cuz if
they just rush on the bridge and he cuts
it cuz she cut you kind of know they're
probably gonna do it but it's like he's
late that would have been it's like okay
well action whatever the fact that they
just built that up so slowly and the
music made closer they ought to go
really slow and they raises the sword
then they bring another woman and the
kid and then the villain gets on the
changes yeah we're doing what we build
up in that scene and then of course the
Brits come and save the day
it said the other house said like I love
about this movie it's just it's so
freakin racist I'm just amazed at her
like you could not make this film
nowadays I don't think cuz it's just
like yes like let's have the white guy
with the white woman and the Chinese
stereotype waltz into this like den of
like nasty Indian stereotypes and then
gets saved by a bunch of Brits firing
their muskets I personally was very
insulted by Dan Aykroyd's British face
he obviously was not British why the
Queen cast British guy I don't know but
I was very offended but yeah I love like
this like looking back on it now like
cuz it's now 2017 that came at what 1984
83 somewhere there I'm just like lay out
like hilariously like jaw-droppingly so
a lot of those eighties films are and
that's
reasons I think they just went for
aliens in kingdom of crystal skull cos
like oh these religious babies were
released today they just be like what
the hell are you doing hey like with any
of the religious angle at all I know
what you mean you have like the cultural
we're Temple of Doom - but it's like any
other religious angle it's like no
that's the problem with Temple of Doom
though is it's the cultural angle it's
like yes we're gonna take Hindi beliefs
and then like there's this weird freaky
cult that's doing all this weird shit
and there's like the thing with Raiders
and Last Crusade is the religious angle
is pretty innocuous it's just like who
doesn't want to see Nazis getting their
asses blown off by the arc like that
that would have been anybody's wet dream
it doesn't want to get chosen poorly
yeah you know same thing with the Holy
Grail ones so it's it's very much
religions on kind of like the good side
because nobody likes Nazis
I used to think that now I know in
theory at least in the 80s when I grew
up nobody like Nazis so but yeah Temple
of Doom gets a little shady or I'm just
like huh okay apparently George Lucas
had some issues after Iain of an Indian
restaurant
I don't feel like the other movies too
it's like you know just like this again
these religious of peace fucking and
please have you read the Old Testament
you see Prince of Egypt there's a
fucking Angel of Death nobody kills
kiddo so that's what I'm saying no what
they didn't Raiders was light hearted
know what I'm saying now you know sort
of going that extreme and that intense
and stuff it's like I don't think a
these movies would have really flown as
I don't know considering her how it
falls in the political spectrum that
might be some revenge fantasy know with
the movie engine I don't see that as a
problem I temple temple gets kind of
shady for me am i huh like to probably
the motion but
yes I I definitely feel I feel that out
of the series temple falls into that
like nefarious Phantom Menace category
of brocade was perfectly regal no Road
visa you know it's weird because I'm not
like it's obvious religion like in all
those fields is just like you can't you
know I want to introduce my son to
Christianity or something there let's
show them you know Raiders a lost but um
but it came to like just initial prize
wrap up here we've been going for a
while I will say that it's like Kingdom
Crystal Skull for me even for all its
like really big problems and stuff like
that it's just kind of doll okay well
that's just a be action film that's kind
of in and I don't like a lot of choices
and stuff we're at least with temple the
temple said temple the Temple of Doom
it is just so insane I think wasn't
either spear where Luke it's like going
through a divorce at the time oh nothing
really hair Lee both an event is said
like well you were like man you're in a
bad place I think there was a
synergistic effect like I'm in a bad
mood I'm in the bed yeah let's just
let's make a shitty bad mood movie it is
it is a fascinating film because of that
you Cersei Kingdom Crystal Skull it's
like I don't know I didn't hate it I
just kind of forgot about it
and they're like okay dumb scenes there
are some good scenes and it's gone it's
the only one that is he wanted to do a
haunted house film apparently the story
goes I think that from what I hear Lucas
wanted to do a haunted house film and it
is the only Indiana Jones that does not
have this kind of grand story of the the
arc and we're going to eighteen years is
one creepy everybody it's yeah this is
the only one where it's really just like
and we're stuck in what is essentially a
haunted house I mean it's in it's an
devil but it's it's a haunted temple
it's a Temple of Doom and literally the
title just says it is the Temple of Doom
whereas the other one that the Last
Crusade it's this big quest to the king
Vader is not the long
the kingdom of the Crystal Skull it's
like well at least it's King the kingdom
yeah like raiders of laws or get outside
this one's the temple of pretty much
says what it is like in on that level
I'm kind of like yeah I'm okay with it
again to me this is just it's an alright
film with some really low moments that
make me want to like fast-forward or
switch the station and come back to it
but I there is not a single part of
Crystal Skull want to see again yeah
that's the problem Temple of Doom it's
lawyers II nothing with everything where
is this mine I'm like I want to see
scenes in this they're funny scenes in
this movie there's great scenes the bad
see the bad scenes are so obnoxious so
annoying so ear greeting but the good
scenes are so you're doing so
interesting and so imaginative where
yeah we came to Crystal Skull the bad
scenes are just dull the good scenes are
it's still dull you know they're just
kind of and you know I've seen this and
that film I see man if nothing really
it's hard to try to figure out a say
because he's like maybe this would have
just been better as a straight-up horror
movie oh yeah and I'm like well but I
mean I do like some of the funny scenes
I'm like well maybe this would have been
better as a straight-up screwball comedy
I'm like well no that would mean more
cake abscesses there's no easy way to
say it so I will be honest like I would
my enjoyment of this movie would at
least go up like 30 40 % if they just
got rid of the woman in the kid if it
was just a colleague alien vs. predator
if it was just indie when this just be
like what what's gonna happen I mean
would you just be so much more intrude
then again it was I will say this though
like seeing this movie when I was
younger like without shortround
and Kate Capshaw I'm not sure like this
movie still intense and if you remove
even them I'm like wow this would be our
Doug who would be our level intent we
were there yeah we were allowed to see
Raiders and lastly is goddamn intense I
see friends house I think when I was 10
and even then that was a cool I will say
Oh
I thought it was really intense like as
a ten-year-old like I saw it at a
friend's house I'm like but we were not
allowed to see it we were able to see
Last Crusade yeah em Raiders but let's
see I guess there's some intense scenes
and last courtesy Raiders it starts off
super intact that's another one I'm like
how the hell is this a PG this should
have been an R it'd be at all no you
wanna know how to got out of that how
okay
this is the one thing they had to change
- when Belloc's faces shoots for some
reason they were just like Oh
stand back that's too intense we've seen
that one too intense but a really kind
of what I felt was a very fakie
explosion of a head that's too much
we're gonna give you our ratings they're
like well what could we do well if you
like blur toes like alright we're gonna
put some fire in front of that face of
it okay your PG movie now totally now
the scene with the corpses and the
skeletons and the boy coming out with
the eye still intact
totally fine oh the the modally fine wax
melting faces I'm like yeah as a kid I
thought yeah it's kind of scary but that
scene where Marion gets stuck with the
corpses of Goku and that like I already
like as a kid was like and we were
watching some video cuz like this came
out 19 yeah I couldn't see it was bad
was right under the blanket time for me
yeah no she's just right in that moment
but when she turns around in that giant
boa constrictor out of the skull I I
literally was like her and that's what
she freaks the fuck out yeah that's what
I was doing that scene is fucking
terrifying and and they're like oh no we
gotta cover up the head exploding but
the time we got to that point the face
is melting I'm like I'm all right just
long as I'm not with the corpses in that
just she's knows it for me cuz the rest
gore wise was pretty intense but I'm
like okay I'm you know I'm a little kid
like I'm taking it in like okay I'm a
big boy big boy let's get through this
and stuff and I
with you when he got to that scene
horseflies what got me I think I just
froze like just something checked out as
soon as the snake was kind of just like
gone traumatize hard I slammed Doug left
his body entirely and honestly what's so
funny about that scene you can just say
there to scare the hell out I give that
80s let's just traumatize you because we
can even earlier in the movie uh
freaking Alfred Molina like with the
with the freaking like date Spears there
is no no no that's adios muchacha I'm
just like does young ringing is frozen
yeah that guy frozen hinted that a dick
joke so same thing ah me more total
bullshit apparently the MPAA thought
despite all of that should in the movie
you know or even the implied like german
guy turn around like with the propeller
in this place all of that that's fine
but the fake exploding face that looked
so fucking at me what did it you gotta
cover that shit up this is too hardcore
for kids like proof that the MPAA is run
by idiots who don't know jack shit
because I'm just like if you knew
anything about kids you'd know that kids
would be fine with that but you know
fucking snakes coming out of corpses
like we that was up there with the pool
scene in like poltergeist yeah which is
another one now like worried yeah I'll
never got me the clown and pole the guys
but when she falls in that pool with all
the like I thought was alive but because
they were older guys that's what they
say bad stories become more and more up
in the air okay fine I would still
either bully every I didn't believe it
is real but I'm like I've heard three
different stories one is that you it's
not true the other story is it is true
and the story I've heard like it was
like there really is that no they were
not really whole cadavers muscles
attached and everything they were real
skeletons that you would use for like
medical display
that they then added makeup and stuff to
to make them look like what you I bet
the actual skeletons were quiet I mean
is play fake skeletons apparently back
then it was cheaper to get like it was
dark tired we had an art teacher hope
you remember this but it's gone this
right that was a real human skull and
she said in the old days I do remember
that you could get these things in
fairly cheap and they banned the trade
of it in like the u.s. in the number of
countries cuz like people would
disappear and then all the skull like a
human skull yeah no I can get you two
bodies yeah my guess is is that if they
were real it was that sort of thing and
they threw makeup on him so I don't know
where you get that many corpses in a
state if they smelt it
yeah I wish the directors somebody would
put it to rest once and for all what
they actually did but like a full
description I never get a full
description I want to know exactly what
way down so yeah we get really
sidetracked
we just got saturated to what the fuck a
tease both good and bad Temple of Doom
yeah yeah as I said before I much rather
see insane over dumb cuz insane can
still be intelligent and interesting
fascinating dumb it's just dumb
sometimes you can do dumb right but
crystal skull is just dumb doll dumb
it's a double tub so yeah I don't like
the movie I guess you think it's okay I
for me it's in the okay category if I
watch only the parts I like I actually
I'm just like so isn't that bad if I
have to watch it the whole way through
I'm like this is yes see if I could only
see the good scenes I would say okay
like this is decent if us Brad he's like
oh that's hands-down the best in the
aperture time it is it is no like alesis
but yeah it's I really want to review a
cuz I was so sick of everyone just being
like how could crystal skull insult this
trilogy of perfect I'm always like wait
a minute do you know cuz everyone's just
totally it's like Ghostbusters - just
forgot they don't like this movie ya
know I've got a lot of problems with
Crystal Skull but things like the nuking
the fridge and how could you put
something that unrealistic in a movie
and I'm like guys it's fucking people
getting their hearts pulled out the by
far the most annoying character we have
ever had it in the edge really dingy
from a plane that's about to crash down
the mountain over the waterfall through
the woods to grandmother's house we go
into the Indian village like there's so
many things that I'm just like and
there's problems with Crystal Skull and
I'm like they come down to writing they
come down the way the film is space
there's a hundred things those stupid
little things always drive me nuts like
in fat it's the reason that will always
hate this movie really that was like
nuking the fridge reserves is just too
far literally a movie where a knight is
alive for years and years just can't
survive you know what I can't do this
aliens really I'm out I'm like oh so the
500 year old knight who drinks Raleigh
Kyle okay
that made sense like and again I can
totally see yeah I can see that like a
movie I see like either movie I'm gonna
see - I can see why Brad were like that
was anything but Chris Cole that didn't
bother me I'm like having aliens in it
didn't bother me sitting in the magical
step when you look at how the series
goes I'm like okay like if you look at
it as a prequel you start off with
really ancient religion you got sort of
the Hindi thing you're in the jungle
then you move to Judaism ray there's a
Lost Ark then you move to Christianity
with Holy Grail you skip all the rest
and then you go straight to science but
the timeframe it was said it in the 50s
it made sense it wasn't effective as
aliens it was an egg meant that they
were executed horribly I would love to
see like the religious history of like
as an Indian
all these religions are real so it's
like how do they all mesh I'm really
curious help me all go together
Indiana Jones metals Emma let's do the
Sun God of Japan from Mars Indiana Jones
and the Dianetics they always say
they're gonna make another Indiana oh
yeah yeah I you can write the story
yourselves we go do with it as you will
assemble a gym sorry I don't like it for
this all right like it's very much of
reserved like is that so that's about
there we will see you next night thank